[Music]
in sensitive fashion news and oh sorry
I'm so sorry I apologize to this well
anyway I accept my apology or am i
canceled canceled I can't everything you
do from here on out I don't want it I
understand submitted by a Joe Mallya ex
yang gang Joe Molly and yang gay Wow
does that mean are you VP are you does
that mean you're the ticket Oh that'd be
a cool clap they're gonna be the
president
mr. yang is under me I think so do that
guy if I'm talking about math and [ __ ]
that guy talks about how he's Asian in
every sentence oh really
yeah I didn't know that he's like I'm
Asian I know a lot of doctors so funny
that did he every time he speaks no one
challenges him
no one debates they can't be there just
like intimidated he's too smart though
is really good at debating that's why he
can't win really why they won't let him
he doesn't stand up for what they're
about yeah he doesn't play identity
politics so they can't they don't know
what to say
cuz I've seen him go on like other
countries like TV shows and stuff and
they try to trap him and he's just so
smart he flips it around makes the other
person feel dumb like really that's
great I saw him on a bunch of [ __ ] he
was on bench of Heroes thing yeah and he
was great yeah and Bishop is a
conservative too yeah he's a [ __ ]
neocon dude I don't even like neo-cons
but he but I was like dang yang is
[ __ ] dope hmm our neo cons from Star
Trek neo cons are like it sounds like it
that's for sure but they love war very
much they love war okay a fashion
designer thoughts school shooting themed
hoodies were a good idea we're [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] kidding me not [ __ ] kid
look they're bullet holes in armor
what the [ __ ] that's sick
like disgusting there's holes just like
oh god this is I saw this [ __ ] at UCB
parties in like 2007 oh really
people were doing all kinds of show like
this that's the joke that's aged well
look at that guy's face
I like that hoodie no he's probably like
someone's in trouble
no what what if he's like it's gonna
make them use that guy's time this is
genius
so there's Columbine there is Sandy Hook
that's horrible
he's making a statement I guess [ __ ]
runway is that loaded Douglas that's
like a hallway of a art studio in
Hollywood I get it I get the statement I
think it's provocative do I think it's
like the best timing for it but at the
same time he's gonna he wants
controversy right that's why you [ __ ]
when would be the best timing like two
years five years reverb yeah I mean if
there's enough space in between both um
you can you might be fine that's his
message his messages [ __ ] school
shootings know we're hitting 300 years
from now it's the best timing yeah cuz
we could talk about [ __ ] the Greeks
and nobody fails [ __ ] well I feel like
don't don't we still can't really talk
about the Holocaust - right it's too
soon we can't among Asians why why cuz
it's not that personal no I guess like I
think Europeans are more affected by our
Jewish people and like whatever right
but then like internment camps yeah I
mean like if you talk about [ __ ] rape
a Nanking or some [ __ ] right then why
people don't really care as much as
Chinese people care yeah I thought I'd
buy a Rape of Nanking hoodie well that's
just you I can't wear that shell if I'd
go that far I would buy a Rape of
Nanking hot or cold tumblr so one that
you get like it depending on the group
of people here with you get a hide thing
then just like slide down oh I was more
thinking of it keeps my liquid
temperature cooled okay but but I see
we're saying like when I first saw
pictures for sure it's like my immediate
reaction is very distasteful what about
the victims families and all that but
then when I like have time to marinate
honor I really don't know how I feel
about it there's also like First
Amendment freedom of speech and then
there's also like art and I understand
are supposed to be provocative it's
supposed to create emotions and then
there's also like the humanity part and
they all kind of pull me in different
ways Thomas Kinkade is controversial to
me it when I when I look at it I'm like
I get it he's going for controversy
who's Thomas Kinkade
he's the painter of life painter it's
okay
it's controversial [ __ ] yeah totally
it's sort of like I Ansel Adams yeah
it's like trash ass [ __ ] like Walmart
[ __ ] don't get back to a pancake going
back to rippin em King the reason why I
would get the hoodie cuz I feel like
it's a there's some sort of empowerment
and like we've overcome that the tide as
a nation has overcome that so much you
know so I feel like there's like I don't
know I feel like there is some
empowerment in there that's you but
everybody else can take that message
differently because that's their own
kind of like prerogative and that's the
beauty of art right like everyone gets
to chime in and then you bring awareness
and you also bring profits you could do
all kinds of [ __ ] and they don't have to
buy the hoodie on my lahood that's what
I think it's tight about this is it it's
just about he's I think he's [ __ ] on
the school shootings [ __ ] like it wasn't
on my mind I just came back from Hawaii
and I'm not thinking about school
shootings even though it's like
happening a lot but school pride is a
big deal right everyone's always like
school pride school press alright so
then he's like okay here's your school
pride remember this is what your school
is known for and isn't that [ __ ] up
right yeah and in some ways it feels
like it takes the power out of the
school shooters hands mm-hmm well why do
I gotta [ __ ] sell it though is he
selling it please let me give you
something else
so this brand is called destroyed and
there's two founders and they said that
they wanted to make a comment on gun
violence while also empowering the
survivors of tragedy
initially they did not plant
sell this at all but because of the
backlash and because of all the
controversy around this now they're
planning on so that's smart we would do
that I would yeah dude that's so dope I
like that it's like oh well you're gonna
say I'm profiting anyway well [ __ ] it
yeah I got more eyes yeah let's mint the
money baby let's go i buy it if i own
this company that i would never show my
face ever it would be a faceless CEO of
this company yet i think you're not
worried on profiting about it you just
don't want you should worry about
getting shot irony exactly I mean not
everyone's gonna know who you are you
can move so they say like this so these
are two black males that are behind this
this streetwear brand so they're saying
that the fact that their image as young
black males has not been traditionally
awarded for credit for introducing
avant-garde ideas is what they're saying
that so many people have assumed that
their message is lazy because what they
have been taught about black men that's
projection dude job everybody thinks
that black men are lazy and this is lazy
art that I produced wait so do they want
credit is that what they lie are they
like so they're pretty much thing like
they're just pushing you know like the
art like the I get that yeah I agree
with him on that part like oh yeah I
think I think no matter what do if you
do this kind of controversial art
everyone says it's lazy everyone and
then these cats are like see we're black
guys we're not lazy I'm like what nobody
said you weren't what the [ __ ] guys just
relax over there yeah before even
knowing that they were black I would
call this lazy art like all day because
whenever you do shock shocking like
contemporary things
yeah it's everyone thinks that it's lazy
art because it's so simple to do but
it's hard in the simplicity because if
it's like if you if it was so easy why
don't you do it well it's also hard in
the guts area yeah
where it's like I'm gonna paint this
right now and it's [ __ ] take some
real balls yeah I'm gonna take a [ __ ] in
the middle of art gallery face balls
that's hard well one of the cofounders
said sometimes oh actually one of the
cofounders posted this on their
Instagram
is what it says you have to put his
black thumb in there's a shard when he's
black mm-hmm he said if this thing said
I could have cleaned this thumb now I
will say look at it it's filthy
no Jeff come on you've been working on
his garden oh yeah Oh underneath the
nail bro Jesus I don't know all right so
this said sometimes life can be
painfully ironic like the irony of dying
violently in a place you consider to be
safe controlled environment like school
we are reminded at we're reminded all
the time of life's fragility shortness
and unpredictability yet we are also
reminded of its infinite potential it is
this push and pull that creates the
circular motion that is the cycle of
life Nirvana is the goal we hope to
achieve through meditation and healthy
practices that counter our destructive
habits samsara is the cycle we must
transcend to reach nirvana little colty
for me I was following him and I was
like halfway through I was like holy
[ __ ] is kicking in I'm like once I got
to Nirvana I was like okay I've lost you
dude the first paragraph yeah
weirdo I was on the board went into like
hyperspace yeah it did a little bit but
but my brains back here do you know any
organic people like this I know I know
you planning unfortunately but I know I
didn't they want to talk about energy
and [ __ ] all the time and I'm like what
have you gotten your crystals right
recently know what I should I do like I
do like the branding of it cuz I like so
I'm a big fan of branding and like
business and stuff and when I can think
of other products for the company that I
know other branding strong brands if
they had like the Angeles fire
collection and all those hoodies are
kind of charred a little bit or maybe
the Louisiana floods where it's like
sweatpants but it comes soggy or classic
that'd be pretty cool and I could just
start brainstorming all kinds of
products for them to the natural the
Amazon fires and it's just like people
being bored because it's very boring
story that we got back to that watch as
the boy was a boring story I'm sure you
want to hear about spider-man right I
wanted to hear about what happened with
spider-man leave an MCU
they were fighting so hard for it yeah
no one's talking about it no more yeah
stalling for the families though like
that the victims families from these
school shootings they're so upset it
must be hurt yeah yeah they're so good
don't remind me of this [ __ ]
no they're just saying like it seems as
if they're making a mockery of how their
family members died well that's how they
see it you know why I think it's a
mockery because they used bills [ __ ]
model boys they should have used [ __ ]
insel lookin boys don't use hot boys
then yeah use insel boys those boys need
jobs anyway their needs go sit at home
why would you use such hot men just like
you're joking yeah so you're trying to
temp straight men with those kind of hot
men right yeah well yeah when I look at
that like wow this is this is sexy your
sexy we're right all right yeah then why
they wear pants well can we not end it
you can keep carrying Joe how hot are
they very hot boys you know and I okay
like if their pants were off and they
have really hard dicks I think the
families will be cool I think you're
right don't [ __ ] do this [ __ ] yeah
with the hottest boys in town soft dick
boys and they're thinking this isn't
respectful yeah if those are raging
boners instead now that's showing
respect I can see it I'm glad we kept
this video going I really am
[Music]